foreign
we live in a culture that is always
changing always evolving always reaching
greater and greater Heights of Tolerance
and Enlightenment and as everyone knows
the Vanguard of this movement the
Warriors up on the front lines fighting
the hardest for Progress the people we
look to first and foremost for guidance
and insight are corporate Brands and
most specifically candy companies we
would be facing grave civilizational
Peril without the leadership of candy
we would be lost without Candy's wisdom
the ancient Greeks had Aristotle at
Plato
we have Reese's Peanut Butter Cups and
Starbursts
our philosophers are more Progressive
wiser
even better you can eat them
2022 was a landmark year for candy
Centric social justice it seemed that
every candy brand was stepping up to the
plate so to speak for example Mars
Incorporated announced it in in May of
2022 that Skittles would be teaming up
with glad to bring us Pride Skittles for
pride month now Skittles had for several
years prior turned their Skittles all
gray for pride month to symbolically
represent the Brand's cemented quote
unquote support for LGBT rights
because who wouldn't want to you know uh
eat uh
cement themed candies but in 2022 they
took it up a notch hiring a collection
of LGBT artists to create special LGBT
art for the packaging it's estimated
that approximately from the numbers I
read 98 000 homosexuals were saved from
persecution because of the Skittles
packaging KitKat also spoke out
forcefully in defense of gay rights all
at Wonderman Thompson which is the
consultant firm that came up with this
gay rights campaign explain it here it
is
Canada's lgbtq i2s population has risen
to over 1 million
but hate crimes discrimination and
mental health issues have also continued
to rise
lgbtq i2s Community needs a break and
KitKat wanted to help so we reimagined
its iconic brand identity to redefine
what it means to take a break for those
who really need one
we partnered with Toronto lgbtq i2s
organization friends of Ruby to help
Young People Express who they are
our partnership was launched with a
video that celebrated a full spectrum of
identity and love
[Music]
we created two limited edition KitKat
flavors and sold them at the Kit Kat
chocolatory all proceeds were donated to
friends of Ruby
we also sent the pride bars along with
custom mailers to lgbtq i2s influencers
wow kitkat's traditional slogan is give
me a break which is exactly what most
people say to themselves when they hear
the acronym
lgbtqi2s so this campaign really makes a
lot of sense I suppose it's like a it's
kind of something meta going on here but
as heroic has the efforts of KitKat and
Skittles were they obviously paled in
comparison to M Ms indeed M Ms have been
civil rights Pioneers for a long time
they are the Martin Luther King Jr of
candies some have said last year they
redesigned their candy mascots to be
more inclusive the changes were nothing
if not bold and dramatic most startling
of all the green m m ditched her iconic
high heels in favor of sneakers because
M Ms had decided they could no longer
enable those Legions of misogynistic
perverts who have candy related foot
fetishes all the other Eminem characters
underwent their own makeovers in the
hopes of making them more sympathetic
and relatable to a new generation that's
what Eminem said they wanted we needed
to sympathize with and relate to these
characters because of course it's
important to sympathize with and relate
to
an object that you're about to eat
this ability to see something as human
and yet also consume it will at least
come in handy when we all turn to
cannibalism during the forthcoming
apocalypse I suppose but that was 2022.
now it's a new year and I'm pleased to
report that M Ms will be aggressively
defending their Crown as the world's
wokest candy the new year will bring new
problems as the left continues their
vicious attack on religion and morality
but you and I can continue to fight the
good fight by remaining rooted in our
faith the best way to do that is with
hallo hallo the number one prayer rap in
the world is everything I need to
maintain a daily prayer routine it's got
over 6 000 audio guided prayers
meditations and peaceful music playlists
plus daily reminders will encourage you
to keep up with the routine start the
new year with daily Bible readings and
Reflections from the number one
Christian podcast which is the Bible in
a year or pray alongside Mark Wahlberg
Jim Caviezel or Jonathan Rooney who
plays Jesus in the new hit streaming
series The Chosen just like physical
exercise daily spiritual exercise is
critical to your well-being especially
in a world where attacks on faith and
religion are happening all around us
every day try Halo for three months free
at halo.com Matt Walsh that's hello.com
Matt Walsh today parade has this report
quote for the first time ever select
Eminem packaging will feature a cast of
all female characters parent company
Mars is releasing the new packaging to
Spotlight Dynamic female Eminem
characters in celebration of women
everywhere who are flipping the status
quo as revealed in a January 5th press
release the limited edition packs
feature brown green and recently
introduced purple and will exclusively
contain brown green and purple candies
the M M's brand is on a mission to use
the power of fun to create purposeful
connections as we work to create a world
where everyone feels they belong
Gabrielle Wesley Chief marketing officer
margs Wrigley North America said in a
release women all over the world are
flipping how they define success and
happiness while challenging the status
quo so we're thrilled to be able to
recognize and celebrate them and who
better to help us on that mission than
our own Powerhouse spokes candies green
brown and purple to represent the flip
the packaging shows the three female
spokes candies standing upside down
above a note supporting women flipping
the status quo
now apparently there will be milk
chocolate peanut and peanut butter
versions of the new packages which is
good because just like female human
beings as we've learned there's no
reason why the female M M's can't have
nuts needless to say this latest
campaign by Eminem's
has already been a a source of great joy
and inspiration for women all over the
country and the globe in fact I have
seen this firsthand I walked into my
living room yesterday and uh and I'll
never forget this
um I I found my wife and my daughter
embracing each other and smiling just
tears of pure happiness streaming down
their faces and my wife turned to me and
said uh she said didn't you hear the
news and I shook my head now like
everybody else I'm on the Eminem email
list so that I can read all of their
press releases and PR statements as soon
as they come out but somehow I've missed
this one I don't know how and my wife
then took me by the hand and she said to
me
they're making an all-female m m package
and I was floored I I didn't know what
to say it was the most amazing thing I'd
ever heard in my life
the courage and heroism of Mars
Incorporated
had once again left me speechless
and then through tears my wife and
daughter they both announced in unison
we've never felt so empowered and
inspired and together we all we all went
it was it was beautiful
and no doubt a scene repeated all around
the world now
there are those of a more critical
disposition who have ruthlessly mocked
this latest example of what they would
describe as awoke corporate virtue
signaling but these people are nothing
but cynics nihilists even they lack the
purity of heart necessary to fully
appreciate what M Ms have done
they're so jaded they can't even admire
an international corporate conglomerate
brand when it comes up with an uplifting
marketing campaign designed to empower
women and also sell candies with 18
grams of processed sugar per serving and
there are still other critics who you
know they've pointed out that while Mars
Incorporated is empowering women with
purple candy
they're also facing a lawsuit filed last
year by eight Africans from the Ivory
Coast who say that they were used as
slave labor on Cocoa plantations
it's hard you know they say to take
their empowerment seriously when they're
also profiting from the enslavement of
human beings allegedly
and to that I say
yeah but still
the point is that M M's are empowering
everyone
except for the slaves allegedly
and that's what we should be focused on
and that is why once again the critics
and the naysayers certainly not M Ms or
Mars Incorporated
are today canceled
and I will do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope see you there if not talk to
you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]